[Musique]
salut sky on espère que tu vas bien et
que tu es bien rentrer au texas après
ton séjour linguistique et culturelle
dans la tribune on a décidé de faire
cette petite vidéo pour quelques
n'oublie pas la réunion il faut répondre
à la question qui nous avait posé un
jour on avait même préparé une pancarte
pour t'accueillir qui arrivent et qui
nous a salués ou s'est présentée laissez
moi c'est bizarre cette attaque n'a
recommandé aux lumières
bon eh bien c'est ça je suis plaisir de
-38 me suis dit bon touche que gatti
trois chauffards ce good life
comment vous dire j'aime bien créer les
ignames bien même bien une face aux sas
on en a qui nous a posé la question
j'avais l'intuition c'est quoi pour vous
être visionnées et aimer pour moi est
chic sas c'est le duo louis kubango
c'est quoi pour vous être réunionnais je
me suis jamais vraiment posé la question
mais quoi on va manger aillent tous
construits tu découvert le goût de
swatch pays
on va manger un bon rougail saucisses
ici on lui raconter l'histoire de grands
merkel a cool validé qu'as tu as tu
racontes trop bien vas-y août et par
moments elle comprend pas trop bien une
ancienne légende de la rue
wasquehal téléphone déclare don
l'idée fait la magie noire il est mort
décapité aura mis à mal en thérapie
bullard sur l'esprit mis en place et
mégane iii en australie en asseoir zones
noires qui crient quand va pas reprendre
un pape en état nauséeux qui ressemble à
un nez avec igor
mais gentil
le soir à lauryn hill été kidnappé par
niort lutte et emmène dans la forêt et
lui tellement grosse qu'elle veut dire
c'est que les enfants qui ne sont pas
savent et des manques dans la forêt ok
[Musique]
écoute l'expérience soûlard now compte
ses couettes réunis nous enfin la
réponse à cette question ne l'a pas
d'une réponse parce que nous tu es
tellement surpris quand la partie l'art
des réponses et la nouvelle économie
[Musique]
et
ah je peux en forme et menaces avec tout
ce qui se passe en ce moment pour moi
trop réunionnaise c'est la diversité des
couleurs et des cultures qu'on retrouve
dans notre métissage la réunion c'est
les magnifiques paysages naturels tels
que la vue du volcan où même les fils
hao que l'on a un peu partout sur cette
ive ou même les chants voyant à noël
pour moi ce qui représente le plus la
réunion c'est les plats plus ou moins
épicé comme le rougail saucisses ou le
cari poulet pour moi notre identité
c'est notre culture
les légendes unique de la réunion tu
sais comme grand-mère calque tu connais
maintenant mais aussi notre langue le
créole parce que pour moi parler créole
c'est le plus important que tu es à
savoir ici parce que créole koz kréol
nouveau départ on a raison wallemme et
one la page
l'horizon famille proche
l'âge et même si familles vivent en
marge
ma contini effet ça sort
où samy savalli traces me coller aux
amis ça trouve mon place
elle place au samu
m
pas fait le sage est mal placé pour saab
mais c'est le genre de mountain à la
tête dans les nuages élevés chanter
crier haut et fort le vrai message me
wade pays primé oicv lettre à la page
niwa 7 pelvis au mode de money vit
dedans comment sautille accès bellemans
sa part évident du temps il fallait par
évidement m'a pas tant magie s'agit
logiquement
mardi les changements ne m'a pas vu le
temps passer
mapa ville